merci mais on a on a une en bronze soit
ton frère ben ouais mon poste
alors là vous allez voir ça ça va vous
plaire aussi l'année alors il va bouder
cas là c'est très simple on arrête des
gens dans la rue on leur pose une
question pendant qu'ils répondent à la
question va vite dans un camion de se
changer en a plein d'accessoires et on
essaie de revenir dans leur ressemblant
le plus possible ou pas assez bien mais
vu ça j'ai pas vu mais c'est bien ça va
être sympa
[Musique]
oui nous expliquer il va dans la rue est
pas là des gens ouais il va dans une
camionnette échange un camion dit comme
ça ça peut faire
bizarre regardez là nous dire ce que
vous en pensez après regardez qu'est ce
que vous pensez des transports en commun
parisiens mais c'est qu'à nice
kelly
c'est assez compliqué parce que il ya
souvent du monde
c'est pas toujours l air
ça on pense quoi
le sort
nous sommes les deux bonasse et sur le
suivi du gpo je suis obama ben c'est
super efficace parce qu'il n'y a pas
besoin de prendre de voiture et je pense
que si je viderai à paris ce qui
n'arrivera pas je voudrais je n'ai pas
de voiture je prendrais juste le
transport en commun et votre chat en bon
choix
ma soeur baala s'est luxé caméra 4 non
c'est une connerie
alors ça avait tout le monde dort futur
sexy l'air
st je m'en sers tous les jours quand
même on sert tous les jours
pour l'étudier pour aller pour le
travail je m'en sert régulièrement donc
un c'est votre heure en pense quoi
pareil à peu près dans les grandes
lignes on parle transports je fais
uniquement rampant dans ce ca muscles
énormément le périnée bonne journée
plutôt frangin bon c'est pas mon vrai
frère mai
ben si je pense au maillage du métro je
trouve ça génial parce qu'on pose est
agacé n'importe où sans avoir besoin de
sa voiture dans les couloirs de bus ça
prend peut-être un petit peu sur la
circulation des deux auteurs de huit je
peux comprendre que pour certains ça
pose problème mais globalement je trouve
que c'est plutôt une réussite très lent
penses quoi
pareil si on le prend de temps en temps
et que c'est beau ça demande
excellent j'adore
[Musique]